basing your understanding of the world
on data rather than journalism the
problem with journalism being that it is
a highly non-random sample of the worst
things that have happened in any given
period it is an availability machine in
the sense of hey miss versky and daniel
daniel kahneman's availability heuristic
namely our sense of risk and danger and
prevalence is driven by
anecdotes and images and narratives that
are available in memory whereas the
since a lot of good things are either
things that don't happen like a country
at peace or a
city that has not been attacked by
terrorists which almost by definition
are not news
or are things that build up
incrementally a few percentage points a
year and then compound like the decline
of uh extreme poverty we can be uh uh
unaware we could be out to lunch about
what's happening in the world if we base
our view on the news instead we base our
view on data then not only do we see
that many although not all things have
gotten better not linearly not uh not
without uh setbacks and reversals but
but uh in general a lot better
and it also uh paradoxically because as
i've uh also cheekily put it uh
progressives hate progress but the best
possible case for progress that is for
striving for more progress in the future
for being a true progressive
is again not to have some kind of
foolish hope but to look at the fact
that progress has taken place in the
past and that means
why should it stop now
[Music]
hello everyone i'm very pleased today to
have with me speaking dr stephen pinker
and dr jonathan height
dr pinker is an experimental
psychologist who conducts research in
visual cognition psycho-linguistics and
social relations he grew up in montreal
and earned his ba for mcgill and his phd
from harvard
currently john stone professor of
psychology at harvard he has also taught
at stanford and mit
he's won numerous prizes for his
research his teaching in his books
including the language instinct how the
mind works the blank slate the better
angels of our nature the sense of style
and enlightenment now he's an elected
member of the national academy of
sciences a two to two time pulitzer
prize finalist a humanist of the year
a recipient of nine honorary doctorates
and one of foreign policies world top
100 public intellectuals and times 100
most influential people in the world
today he writes frequently for the new
york times the guardian and other
publications
he's publishing his 12th book september
28th 21 21 this year september 28th it's
called rationality what it is why it
seems scarce and why it matters
dr jonathan height is a social
psychologist at nyu's stern school of
business his research
examines the intuitive foundations of
morality and how morality varies across
cultures including the cultures of
american progressive conservatives and
libertarians
the happiness hypothesis finding modern
truth in ancient wisdom the righteous
mind why good people are divided by
politics and religion
and the coddling of the american mind
how good intentions and bad ideas are
setting up a generation for failure he
co-authored that with greg lueken off
the last two books each became ny times
bestsellers
at nyu stern he's applying his research
on moral psychology to business ethics
asking how companies can structure and
run themselves in ways that will be
resistant to ethical failures
he's also the co-founder of
heteroxacademy.org a collaboration among
2500 professors working to increase
viewpoint diversity and freedom of
inquiry in universities he has a
forthcoming book three stories about
capitalism the moral psychology of
economic life expected to release in
2022.
thanks gentlemen very much for agreeing
to talk to me and to each other today
looking forward to a
wide-ranging and
intense conversation so
we haven't jonathan we haven't talked
for about two years i guess that's right
i've always been a great fan of your
research especially research on on
disgust and other moral sentiments i'm
kind of wondering what you've been up to
recently so maybe you can start us off
sure uh so after i moved to stern in
2011 i'd been at the university of
virginia
i got interested in how moral psychology
doesn't explain why it doesn't just
explain why our politics is so messed up
it also explains a lot of conflicts
about economics and business and so
uh i i saw
left and right
unable to understand each other's views
of business and capitalism and i thought
i'd write a book on it and i got a book
contract in 2014 and i went off to asia
to do research for the book and i came
back and i was all ready to write when
the universities blew up
at halloween 2015
and i just co-founded heterodox academy
and then i got hijacked into uh a lot of
uh
well the cod lead the american mind
stuff and that basically occupied me for
three or four years
the capitalism book was due in 2017 and
finally i have a sabbatical i've i've
got to write it if i don't write it now
i don't know when i ever will
but it's basically about how to think
about economics in a way that gets you
out of the moralism um maybe a theme
that i'll explore today is how moralism
messes everything up at least about
trying to figure out what's going on or
trying to do research what do you mean
by moralism
uh moralism is if you look at things in
a framework not of true versus false but
of right versus wrong bad versus good
once you put on that frame
tyler cowan has a quote somewhere in a
ted talk he says
we think in stories but as soon as you
put a good evil story as soon as you
interpret things in terms of a good evil
story your iq drops by 10 to 15 points
and i think that's right it seems like
kind of like a case of over
generalization in some sense right you
want to discuss a narrow issue
assuming consensus on everything you're
not talking about and then if you
transfer that into
let's say uh
a mutual
elaboration of both your characters on
the scale of good and evil all it does
is make things exceedingly complex that
never works in a marital argument for
example for example that's right right
we had a rule in our relationship my
wife and i that
we would try to argue about the
narrowest possible thing
in the given argument right
to stop it from
expanding ever outward and and
potentially turning into a
characterological attack
yeah that yeah that's that's a good way
that's a good sounds like a good rule uh
because
at a certain point arguments become
all-out war where the goal is not you
lose all touch with truth and your goal
is to win and strangely you win in ways
that alienate the very person you're
trying to persuade
because so much of our argumentative
ability is actually intended for an
audience we're really really good at
making our case
uh even though it often doesn't persuade
the other person but because we evolve
for moral grandstanding uh in
very intense social groups and that's a
little foreshadowing of how i hope we'll
talk about social media
so you see that as go ahead dr baker
well i'm going to add something to
john's point having looked at data on
violence on historic scales in my
previous book better angels of our
nature i have a somewhat cheeky
paragraph that says the world has far
too much morality by which i meant far
too much moralization alluding to the
fact that history's greatest bloodbaths
were not caused by
greedy um
vdk is feathering their own nest
accumulating palaces and harems uh they
were moralistic crusades they were
people committing violence because it
was not only permitted but obligatory in
service of a higher cause a lot of
bloodthirsty dictators were ascetics and
uh they were not uh they were they were
not motivated by agreed they were
motivated by what in their own eyes was
was morality which we call moralization
doesn't mean we should also all be
amoral psychopaths there is such a thing
as morality but moralization the
psychology of the moral sense which john
has done uh so much to illuminate can be
a source of immorality judged
objectively okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
google cheeky paragraph steve pinker too
much morality there we go
so
stephen in your book
um
enlightenment now and other works
you've been
tarred and feathered so to speak as an
optimist i mean you make the case that
things are improving and there's there's
a number of public intellectuals who
make the same sort of argument bjorn
longberg for example matt ridley
uh uh mary and toopey all of detailed
ways that the world has improved
dramatically over especially over the
last 30 years but certainly over the
last 150 and yet we seem to be
polarizing terribly at the moment and so
what do you think is driving that given
that you know arguably things are better
than they have been
yeah i tend to uh
try to squirm out of the
optimist pigeonhole because i'm not
arguing for looking on the bright side
and seeing the glasses half full
but rather just basing your
understanding of the world on data
rather than journalism the problem with
journalism being that it is a highly
non-random sample of the worst things
that have happened in any given period
it is an availability machine in the
sense of amis tvski and
daniel kahneman's availability heuristic
namely our sense of risk and danger and
prevalence is driven by
anecdotes and images and narratives that
are available in memory whereas the uh
since a lot of good things are either
things that don't happen like a country
uh at peace or a uh a city that has not
been attacked by terrorists which almost
by definition are not news
or are things that build up
incrementally a few percentage points a
year and then compound like the decline
of uh extreme poverty we can be
uh unaware we could be out to lunch
about what's happening in the world if
we base our view on the news instead we
base our
view on data then not only do we see
that many although not all things have
uh gotten better not linearly not uh not
without uh setbacks and reversals but
but uh in general a lot better
and it also
paradoxically because as i've also
cheekily put it
progressives hate progress but the best
possible case for progress that is for
striving for more progress in the future
for being a true progressive
is again not to have some kind of
foolish hope but to look at the fact
that progress has taken place in the
past and that means
why should it stop now
we know that it's possible
so that's the
do you think that it's a reasonable
thing to do from a rational perspective
to compare the present to the past
rather than to i mean we there is a
tendency to compare the present to a
utopian future and i mean that's kind of
a cognitive heuristic because we're
always looking
for ways to make things better and i
suppose that's that tendency taken to
its extreme but
it does seem to me that
some of the decrying of the current
situation is a consequence of comparing
it to hypothetical utopia instead of
actual you know other countries or other
times
yeah utopia is a deeply dangerous
concept because people imagine a world
without any problems and since people
disagree with each other that means that
in order to have complete harmony and
agreement you've got to get rid of
all those nuisances those people who are
not on board with your plans for utopia
which is of course why
it's been the utopians that have been
the most um
genocidal regimes in history yeah so i
have a kind of a religious question to
ask you about that this is something
i've been thinking about lately now in
in in
in christianity broadly speaking
you could make the case from a
psychological perspective that utopia is
permanently forestalled into the future
in in that in the name of the afterlife
or of heaven or something like that so
it's abstracted up into something that's
then put in a distant
place and i'm wondering to some degree
if that's not a consequence of attempts
to
remove the danger from assumptions of
potential utopias here and now
now because i'd like to look at
religious thinking from an evolutionary
perspective or a biological perspective
and it's very curious to me that the
idea of
of the utopia let's say would be
forestalled in that way
what any any thoughts about that
no it's a strange question
well we have ideas about heaven
um that seem to be not universal but
there are
features of heaven that seem to occur
maybe we'll get into this later if we
talk about psychedelics but there are
certain visions of heaven and hell
and so the idea of having which often
seems so perfectly beautiful the idea of
it's perfectly beautiful but you know
it's got its weird political problems
and these people like that just doesn't
make any cognitive sense better to have
it all be good and perfect and pure and
hell be all you know perfectly terrible
um so i don't know what was motivating
the early christians i have no insights
into that
but
something that a way that i do
psychology and actually uh jordan i know
that you do too because when we first
met you when i first met when i had my
first job interview at harvard in 1994
and you were the only person on the on
the faculty then that i that i connected
with but we both bonded over an interest
in young and while i don't embrace the
you know the uh you know the sort of the
um
some of the more fanciful elements of of
young the um but the idea of of
archetypes the idea that there are
things images that occur to people
around the world uh because they come
out of our evolutionary past something
about our minds readily imagines them
because of some something was adaptive
long ago
uh and so
that's what got me into the study of
disgust and puritan pollution was when i
started reading ethnographies and seeing
that all these cultures that never had
any communication many of them are idled
in nations in the pacific or the or you
know they all had some similar ideas
about purity and pollution and so i
would guess similarly with heaven and
hell
yeah well it's interesting to me that if
earthbound utopias present a continual
political danger in the way that we've
been discussing that one way out of that
might be to permanently forestall it you
know because and we also talked
archetypally already because you guys
mentioned the fact that it's easy for
political discussions to degenerate into
something like an archetypal struggle
between good and evil right it's that
base level category that seems to emerge
and confuse things when they need to be
more specified
you're supposing that there is some sort
of an evolutionary system
that there's been enough competition
between cultures that the ones that were
utopian didn't win out or you're
assuming that
somebody had
access to enough data of world
historical societies to realize that
utopias tend to end in bloodshed and
guess what here we are in 2100 while a
few social scientists know it most
people are still or many people are
still utopian so i think it i i would
not look for some adaptive thing like oh
the christians were very wise in putting
utopia impossibly far in the future
because they knew that if they put it in
the present it'll be no i don't i don't
know i wouldn't think they knew i i
don't i don't imagine it's anything that
was planned it just strikes me that the
idea is so prevalent that utopian
thinking is so prevalent that there
might it might be necessary to develop a
psychological mechanism to make it
to make its existence safe
you know i was thinking in some sense
the same thing about ideas of god
because and i don't know what you guys
think about this but
it seems to me that it's possible that
if there isn't a place in society for
something like an ultimate value then
that degenerates down to the political
level and starts to contaminate it
so if there is such a thing as a
religious instinct let's say if it is
doesn't find its proper place that in
the in abstraction
then
you elevate other elements of of society
to the same level and then that becomes
dangerous
well it depends on what you elevate uh
if it's uh if what you're elevating is
human well-being people should be
healthy and happy and long-lived and
educated and safe that doesn't seem like
such a bad moral value to elevate and
it's certainly better than some
arbitrary stipulation from from uh some
scripture or creed that you can't
justify to people who don't believe it
antecedently i mean the problem with
utopia is i mean among the problems um
and and i'm not sure by the way i'm the
least
qualified person on earth to talk about
christian theology or eschatology but it
seems to me there's also the notion of
the second coming there's a end times
there's heaven on earth
there are notions of utopia that are not
so
not necess seem to be not necessarily
postponed uh indefinitely but the
problem with utopia of course is that
it ignores
the inherent trade-offs in the human
condition
such as that if you give you can't have
uh complete freedom and complete
well-being because people will choose to
do things that screw up their lives so
unless you have a totalitarian nanny
state you give people freedom they're
going to do things that will lead to
some bad outcomes you we're not all
identical and therefore anything that uh
carries out the vision of some of us is
going to to be inevitable to others and
so that's why a liberal democracy is
basically a means for resolving
disagreements not a vision of what life
ought to be there's an inherent
trade-off between
equality of outcome and equality of
uh opportunity or or rights and since
we're not all clones that means that if
you just allow people to
achieve the most they can some people
will achieve more than others and
there is that trade-off if you don't
want to have extremes of uh inequality
uh added to the
uh
the inevitability that whatever your
vision of utopia is going to be not
everyone's going to agree with you and
in order to carry out a scheme that is
perfectly laid out on paper
how do you deal with the people who
don't get with the program if you
sincerely believe
that the people who disagree with you
are the only things standing between
the current world and world will be
infinitely good forever then you're
justified in doing anything possible
there to to eliminate the dlt yeah well
exactly well that's why it seems to be
such a hazard right because
utopia if utopia is perfect and it can
be attained then any means are
acceptable to bring it about and that i
can't think of a more profound moral
hazard than that yeah we're all kind of
channeling isaiah berlin here but uh but
they're good arguments
so yeah i'd like to go ahead if you
don't mind jordan i'd like to um
to take what steve just said which is so
sensible it makes perfect sense yes we
need a liberal democracy for all these
reasons um but yet somehow it's not it
doesn't seem to inspire people the way
that a god does and yes we could elevate
human well-being let's all have a
religion around human well-being and
we'll do whatever it takes to advance
human well-being well um i've spoken i
get invited to speak at christian
colleges and christian associations and
podcasts sometimes because
even though i'm a you know center center
left atheist jew um
they when they read the righteous mind
they find it useful and they see that i
don't have the usual academic contempt
for religion i actually uh think
religion at least in the united states
religion on net is is a very good thing
and so when i speak to christian
audiences i often start off by saying
you know um we actually agree on
something extremely important which is
that there is a god-shaped hole in
everyone's heart and pascal didn't say
exactly that but he said something more
or less to that effect
and i say yeah there's a god-shaped hole
in our heart we just disagree on how it
got there and you think it's there
because we long for god and god exists
and god fills it i think i'm a
naturalist i think we evolve to be
religious and i tell that story in the
righteous mind how we evolve for
sacredness and gods and and and how gods
have evolved culturally um and so i
think central to our conversation here
or rather we're having this academic
conversation in the context of a country
going insane with bad religions and by
bad religions what i mean is people have
found something that fits the whole and
so it's deeply satisfying but it makes
them behave in ways that are incredibly
destructive to a liberal democracy
whereas the older religions at least
went through a process of evolution
especially those that made it in a free
country like america
there they tend to be kind of nice
and so uh so i would i would bring that
perspective okay so yeah so i want to
comment on that a bit i mean
one of the things i've been struck by
talking to lomberg and ridley and and
marion toopey about the idea of human
well-being which is obviously something
that anyone sensible would support is
that it is very very difficult to make
it inspiring and
i i think there are probably two reasons
for that is one is this god-shaped hole
that john was talking about
seems to perhaps indicates that
the that ideal that you mentioned
stephen needs to be embodied in
something like a personality for it to
fit properly rather than for it to be an
abstract idea that might be more
motivating for people who are highly
rational and intellectual
and so
so it isn't obvious to me how an ideal
of say incremental progress towards
well-being which might be regarded as
a prime enlightenment sentiment can be
fashioned in some sense so that it
fulfills the psychological requirements
that jonathan was describing
yeah so i have another if i can allude
to another cheeky passage toward the end
of enlightenment now i say well is do we
need to have uh uh you know men in
colored shirts saluting posters of john
stuart mill and
uh and and secular humanist preachers
rolling back their eyes and pounding a
copy of spinoza's ethics on the pulpit
uh here here so
well maybe we do but on the other hand
and i find
there's some irony in here me defending
uh
the plasticity of a human belief and
values given i'm a pretty staunch
advocate of the concept of human nature
but the what fills that that that
god-shaped hole is uh it's pretty
variable i mean it was certainly there's
nothing in human nature that says that
it had to be filled with the notion that
if you accept that you know a guy who
was nailed to a cross 2000 years ago
died for your sins and and the before
most of which was when adam and eve uh
you know eating the the fruit of the
the fruit of the tree of knowledge i
mean that's not an intuitive idea that
was an idea that we had to have acquired
we also know that uh despite the
prevalence of religious belief there's
an awful lot of the world's population
that does not believe in any deity the
population of china for example a large
portion of the uh population of western
europe in the united states um
millennials and and gen
z's have some vague notion of you know
spiritual but not religious but they're
following their uh uh in droves away
from specifically from formal relations
but that makes them more vulnerable to
these new political religions well
indeed no i i i i i agree but the thing
is that those aren't specifically
they're not literally religious in the
sense that they appeal to the
supernatural or theological they're
crummy moral systems and so it does
leave
open the possibility of having a not so
crummy moral system
but the essential element i think is
that it unites a group against other
groups
so human well-being wouldn't do it but
fighting white supremacy or fighting crt
or the communists or the fascists or
whatever so i think it's it you can't
just put anything in there you know i'm
a durkheimian and so i think a good
religion anything that's going to fit in
the whole and by good i don't mean good
for so i just mean something that will
make a good fit is going to have to be
one that has a group bonding function
for us to come together to fight
something else so let me ask you about
that so
you just made the case i think and
correct me if i'm wrong that
or we seem to agree on the case that
because of this absence of a higher
value whatever it happens to be that's
fallen down into the political domain
and then the quasi-religious impulses
that are infiltrating the
the political domain tend to pit one
side against another so you get a good
versus evil narrative emerge but the
problem with the good versus evil
narrative is that the evil is embodied
in some other group and the good is
embodied in your group so one of the
things i've been thinking through is
that you know in sophisticated
literature
you don't have good guys and bad guys
you have good guys and bad guys in the
same soul and that's the solution
yes right exactly exactly you see that
sophisticated literature everyone knows
that so so here's a thought so if you
don't have a
abstract religious system that insists
that the dividing line between good and
evil is to be fought inside your own
soul so to speak then
it degenerates one step into a battle
between good and evil in the outside
world with evil being conveniently
located somewhere else so i mean one of
the things i think that christianity did
bring the world and it had its roots in
jewish thinking as well was that the
greatest of evils was to be found within
not without and maybe that's one way of
protecting society from this schismatic
tendency that we see re-emerging let's
look let me give you an example okay
i'll just go through this very quickly
so
in the
in the book of genesis in the story of
adam and eve
you have evil located as a snake
right so it's a predator it's the
predator in the garden and predatory
snakes were hell on primates so there's
plenty of evolutionary reason for that
but then you can imag so there's an
insistence in judeo-christian thinking
that the snake in the garden is satan
which is a very odd idea i tried to
think that through i thought okay snake
has predator
other person has predator group as
predator
soul inside your soul as predator
it's increasing psychologization of the
idea of predator because you know when
we were
animals like other animals we were
preyed upon by straightforward predators
and then by other people
and then by other individuals but then
we figured out that that battle was
within
and if it isn't occurring within then is
it necessary that it is transferred to
something that's occurring without
i really like your point about how
believing in original sin or that the
battle is within
makes you less susceptible to a
simplistic where good their evil
narrative i like that a lot i'm a big
fan of amanda ripley who wrote this
amazing essay called complicating the
narrative and it's about how journalists
reporters you know if don't report like
well this side says this and this size
says that don't just report the two
sides that simplifies the narrative in a
sense rather show splits within each
side and show that the story is really
complicated and that kind of stops
people in their in their in their rush
to judgment and mob action and makes
them think which of course is what great
literature does too
and that also helps explain what i think
is is is
particularly attractive to me in in
christianity at least in some of the
christians that i know um is that they
really make a virtue of humility
in a way that uh well jews don't at
least american jews don't don't seem to
um but um
the idea that we are all flawed don't be
so sure of yourself judge not list ye be
judged um so
i sometimes join a group uh of
evangelical uh um preachers actually
brought together by jonathan rauch uh
another jewish atheist but you know with
a bunch of interesting people like pete
weiner david brooks uh uh and some
actual yeah some actual ministers as
well
um but it uh i i just love the
the virtues there of humility grace
forgiveness
and these are virtues that have just
been completely drained away from from
modern society
yeah i think you see the the struggle
for morality within the jewish tradition
in the prophetic tradition with the
insistence that you know people have
deviated away from the path of god and
have to be called back to it so at least
the precursors to that idea are there in
in in broad form and importantly yeah
that makes sense yes
yeah you know the idea that that uh
there's uh a struggle between our our
better angels and our inner demons
between good and evil within us
uh is an important idea it doesn't have
to come from the parable of the snake in
the garden of eden the problem there is
that if it is it's just a parable and
people who weren't raised in the
christian tradition or who just just
don't believe it or can't slide onto it
can reject it but it's not that
abstrusive notion it appears also in uh
freud's contrast between the the uh it
and the superego it appears in
evolutionary psychology in terms of the
particular drives and
motives that served us well in uh in an
anarchic society uh
you see in cartoons with the devil on
one shoulder and the angel on the other
i i i think if we think it's a good idea
we have to articulate why it's a good
idea and express it in a way that anyone
can accept it regardless of the
tradition they have happened to be a
have to have been brought up in
and in terms of the
jewish notion of humility i i'm sorry
but i have i have to tell a jewish joke
which is that on the uh holiest day of
the year yom kippur the rabbi and the
cantor are standing in front of the the
ark of the open ark with the the torah
scrolls the cantor falls to his knees
and says lord i am nothing
the rabbi uh seeing him uh
false his knees says lord i am nothing
in the back of the room of the synagogue
there's the lowly janitor overcome with
emotion he falls to his knees and says
lord i am nothing the rabbi says the
cantor look because he's nothing
so
that's humility within the jewish
tradition
when i was reading enlightenment now and
i i was struck by this
and i guess this is something that's
always struck me is that
there's a there's a power in
mimicry and imitation that's attenuated
in rational reasoning
and so i've been thinking again about
christianity from a psychological
perspective and i thought well one way
you could characterize it is that it's a
very long discussion about what
constitutes the human ideal
and i've been thinking about what unites
people and you might say well that
beliefs unite them but i think it's the
shared pursuit of an ideal that unites
people rather than beliefs about the
state of the world per se and so when i
was reading enlightenment now and when i
read works of other rational
enlightenment types
i'm
it's this it's this inability to inspire
that that torments me because i
appreciate the utility of the arguments
and the power of the technology that's
associated with rational thinking and
all of that but
things seem to be disintegrating
politically around us despite that
rationality and it isn't clear to me
that it's a sufficient force to hold
back the tide i mean look what happened
to dawkins recently with the humanists
for example which was quite shocking to
me and i suspect to him as
well me too yeah
no it is it is a challenge of how to
engage people's uh how to get their
their
their blood pumping their their
adrenaline going uh you know it's a
dangerous thing if it can be
commandeered by by demagogues and by
rabble rousers
uh i think it is
worth it and i think we don't know
enough about this process to look at
cases in which there have been
constructive moral and social movements
that have managed to get to to engage
people's emotions perhaps the civil
rights movement in its heyday of martin
luther king
when john f kennedy got a lot of people
to join the young people to join the
peace corps
uh the founding of the united nations
was a source of great
um uh uh hope
the united nations has its own
pathologies but in its time even in
things like uh there are
there's a kind of
pseudo-religion to some uh ted talks
where you've got a
techno optimist who proposes some uh way
of dealing with with climate change with
malaria with uh parasitic disease
uh and in the room you can feel that
kind of elevation that law
i think we have to work toward not just
engaging any old uh fervor but to figure
out how we marry that fervor to the
causes that generally deserve it
this skeptic here because my new theme
that i'm thinking through
is is unmoralize everything that moral
moralism moral judgment um you know as i
said it's just it it uh makes it
difficult to find the truth and and so
constructive moral and social movements
well we're all supposed to think well
social movements are great
and uh the civil rights movement women's
rights movement uh gay liberation all
the incredible rights movements over the
last 50 or 60 years
but that's in part because we we look
back at the ones that uh that
that were successful and that were
really deeply right about writing
injustices
and
now when i look at social activism
on campus and among young people
i think it
um i have a much greater appreciation
for how hard it is to change
institutions
especially complicated institutions that
are generally trying to
to be open
and humane anyway and i look at the
policies that many young people are
pressing universities to adopt or
pressing
companies to adopt and what i see
happening
is um
un uh unmoored moralism um trying to
change institutions without
understanding them and i'm beginning to
think
that um social activism
may on net be a negative thing
to to the extent that now it is governed
more by the social dynamics of social
media and self-presentation than by any
real study of a problem an attempt to
come up with something that would work
so you know that's blindness blindness
isn't it i mean blindness blindness
they're blind to what they're blind
about yes exactly
well you know you if you put someone on
the spot and you ask them if they could
run a nuclear power plant they'll say no
but if you ask them what should be done
about the entire world's electrical grid
they'll tell you the answer
and that's a good example of not
decomposing the problem down into
into units that could actually be
addressed intelligently but you know so
you're noticing this
this activism and you're doubtful about
its utility and your solution
and we can talk about this more is to
take the moral fervor out of it so i was
thinking recently about john piaget's
argument you know his final stage of
cognitive development hardly anybody
knows this but it was the messianic
stage
well i've never heard about that
absolutely there's many things about
piaget that people haven't heard about
you know that his goal was to unite
religion and science oh
yes i mean piaget is a very strange
character and all you hear about is the
rational stage theory but anyways the
last stage was the messianic and he
identified that as a stage in late
adolescence not everyone reached it but
that it involved a world-changing fervor
and he identified that as part of what
catalyzed identity and so we're seeing
that these students they come to
university they want to catalyze their
identity in a in a profound way and
orient themselves and what seems to
happen is the activist types tap into
that and offer them a solution and the
solution seems dangerous but it doesn't
look like the intelligent people are
offering anything that's useful as an
alternative because they're not getting
anywhere with it
and so we have to ask yourself exactly
why that is
and part of it is the lack of romance i
think
you know when orwell wrote about the
nazis in the 1930s
he was very he was very careful to
highlight
their dramatic use of ritual and their
romantic attraction of course he was
absolutely opposed to everything they
were doing as anyone rightly should be
but orwell was very wise and about human
nature in general
and there's a drama in what's being
offered to adolescents that the rational
approach doesn't seem to engender and i
don't know how to solve that problem i
think it's a terrible problem
but
well
i i can immediate between uh jordan what
you've been saying with what uh children
offered and i i do tend to agree with
john i was trying to make some
concessions toward the possibility that
you could best energize people by
somehow co-opting this uh this fervor
but we i think it's probably an open
question how much can you engage people
without the
the the trappings of religion or
pseudo-religion can you engender a
problem-solving mindset as opposed to a
struggle mindset that's right and you
know before we write write people off
and say no no they can't no one likes
solving problems it's too boring it
doesn't get heart pounding you've got to
they've got to wear colored shirts
they've got to salute something they've
got they've got to bow down you know we
have uh you know we did eliminate
smallpox we've
uh drastically reduced the uh uh amount
of warfare partly because of you know
john and yoko and peter paul and mary
but also because of much more practical
uh treaties and organizations
uh we've drastically reduced uh extreme
poverty not because of uh the teachings
of the hebrew prophets or jesus but
because of
china and indonesia and india adopted
capitalism to to tie into the theme of
uh
john's impending book so
there there is a tendency there's a
vulnerability in people to want to
belong to transcendent movements
involving some kind of conflict on the
other and we haven't done so bad at
combating disease and poverty and war
with a more technocratic problem-solving
mindset so maybe jonathan's right that
we ought to just
minimize uh these dangerous passions and
treat more things as problems to be
solved well my so my concern i agree
with your your description of what came
before
uh but my concern is that is that the
universe is different after 2012 than it
was before 2009 that the fundamental
nature of society was rewired by
everyone going on to social media
especially facebook and twitter but all
the other platforms as well
and so whatever was possible whatever
the arrangements were before
some of that is still valid today but a
lot of it isn't and we often don't know
what parts and so
whether you're talking about how we mode
how we mobilize to solve problems
so just just to take one example
um
activist movements
generally had adults in them they had
adults and then young people would come
into them as well and there was there
were multiple generations of knowledge
about how things work and how they want
to change
uh but now that everyone is connected to
everyone and and if things go at many
times the speed
uh i think you can have a groundswell
for a reform of a system
uh that gets pushed through within days
or weeks
just by people with very little input
from adults and that's why i think we
see over and over again demands
just speaking from the area i know best
on campus you know demands that dozens
and hundreds of schools year after year
for things that make race relations and
inclusion and diversity worse
so um so i'm just concerned and it's
just this is just one little example but
in so many ways
i think the 2010s were weird uh because
life after 2012 is just fundamentally
different from life before 2009.
well do you think go ahead stephen yeah
although i mean i i see that happening
and there has been a change
toward in intolerance and uh uh struggle
as opposed to problem solving the last
few years on the other hand the demands
are being accepted by uh baby boomers by
the deans and the provosts and if you
rewire the tape back to when we were
college students there was an awful lot
of inanity and extremism and repression
of speech eo wilson and dick hernstein
and uh tom bouchard and many others were
cancelled there were posters i have one
from 1984 uh a talk for eo wilson bring
noise makers and now the student
activists of uh when we were students
are now the deans and the provosts who
are happily ratifying these extreme
demands
you know at the same time and then we
all know this from our students this is
not a uniformly woke generation there
are awful awful lot of students who are
uh intimidated into silence and they
think gee i must be the only uh satan
person everyone else is crazy and an
awful lot of people are all thinking
that so i do agree that there is a
problem of uh just mature judgment but
it isn't completely a cohort effect
but that's my point is that it's not a
cohort effect it's a it's a change in
dynamics so it used to be that there
would be some activists uh but other
people could still have a conversation
or they could still have some they could
still play play a role
you're right that the the people giving
in to the demands are people from the
previous generation who were the uh at
least that generation earlier but
they're not happily giving in i've
spoken to many leaders in the academic
world they all hate it um they're they
they are they feel stuck they feel
pressured they don't know what to do
and now it's the same thing people
leading non-profits especially
progressive nonprofits or companies so
it's not that young people are woke it's
that the dynamics have changed so that
they'll woke among the young now have
such power to intimidate others into
silence and this is what we see in
universities that students are not
afraid of their professors they're
afraid of a subset of students and the
professors are not afraid of anyone
except this subset of students and the
presidents well they have other donors
and other people who to please um but
but the dynamics of social media allows
the small group to weaponize their
moralism and to intimidate others into
silence and this is happening in so many
institutions not everywhere
but it is happening and so what we need
to do is not change a generation what we
need to do is change the dynamics so
that uh bad ideas don't dominate and
intimidate
so why do you
single out 2012
so 2009 is when facebook added the like
button and twitter added the retweet
button and before then social media was
not particularly polarizing people would
put up a friendster page or a myspace
page or a facebook page
with what they liked and here's here's
who i am not polarizing at all
and then in 2009 you get
uh the like button and then the retweet
button and then twitter and facebook
copy each other very quickly so now both
platforms have both like and retweet now
both platforms have huge amounts of
information about engagement and now
they can algorithmise all the feeds
and so as it's more engaging this is the
two or three years where uh at least
adolescents i have data or data from
national survey showing this is the two
years when adolescents go from mostly
not being on these platforms every day
to now teen social life is mostly
conducted on on various platforms so do
you think that's so are you
characterizing that as a positive
feedback loop essentially uh the light
buttons with the algorithms
yes exactly it's a feedback loop and
it's also the most powerful uh not
pavlovian it's uh just behaviorist
behaviors conditioning mechanism ever
opera thank you thanks
i haven't taught psych 101 in 10 years
um
but you know if you think about it you
know if you many people have seen that
video of bf skinner training a pigeon to
turn the circle by just reinforcing
slightly more clockwise behaviors
counterclockwise behaviors in the video
and if you think about it as soon as as
soon as someone gets on social media and
they post something um now people are
giving them little reinforcements and so
and it's within seconds i mean people
you post something and then sometimes
you check within a minute what did
people think about it and so we have um
uh so this is why uh so these are ideas
that i developed with tobias rose
stockwell we had an article in the
atlantic on uh why
everything's going hey why democracy is
going haywire or something like that
well the positive feedback loop idea is
really interesting too because a lot of
psychopathologies are positive feedback
loops so if you get depressed and you
start isolating yourself because you're
depressed you get more depressed if you
drink alcohol and go into withdrawal and
then drink to cure that you become
alcoholic if you are agrophobic and you
avoid you get more afraid like a lot of
psychopathological processes are
positive feedback loops and so the
combination of the algorithm with the
like that's we don't know what these
technologies are doing to us we don't
have a clue we have noises
and it's pretty much all bad um so yes
we got that feedback loop that now now
you can have have the echo chambers and
bubbles if you're prone to extremist
politics on either side you now because
based on what you like what youtube
videos you watch that sucks you down
into more extreme ones and into a
community so the algorithms are doing
two things they're picking our friends
because they're going they say you
should meet this person because people
you know meet him so the algorithms are
making our friends different from what
they used to be and the algorithms are
making what we watch and consume
different um and in some ways that's
good because we it's things that we
enjoy
but the one of the problems for a
liberal democracy as the founding
fathers knew is faction factionalism
people become so focused on defeating
the other side they lose sight they lose
concern for the common good well you
might also think that it would be
necessary
like if you go to public school
you go to school with 30 people who are
basically randomly selected from the
population and so then you have to
modify
well
in canada you have to you have to you
have to modify your behavior to take
into account a broad range of people and
you didn't pick them whereas online if
you're starting to only aggregate with
people who think the way that your
interest indicates you think then is it
possible that you start to lose touch
cognitively with the broader culture and
you don't even know what it is anymore
yes and that's
that's right and that's why i'm
particularly concerned about gen z
because
the mental health data shows that their
mental health plummeted beginning around
2012 whereas the millennials they didn't
get social media until they were in
college or after college and i think
that if you um if you're exposed to
a broad range of ideas and books and
people
you have a chance to get your mind
broadened when you're when you're young
but if you think about the the river of
inputs coming into people's eyes and
ears when we were all growing up we
watched way too much television but
television was made by older people it
was made by people who are not children
and so we at least you know from
watching bugs bunny you're at least
exposed to opera and you're exposed to
certain cultural themes and and you know
even have a sense of the 1940s let's say
um
but once everyone got onto social media
all the time now the river of inputs so
much of it was created in the last week
or two by people your age and so there's
just not much room for
people in this post-war you know in the
after times let's say and you know after
the social media world there's not much
room for kids to learn anything about
the 20th century or communism or nazism
uh or great literature
most so much input is jammed up with
trivia ephemera um and to extent that
there's political content it's it's not
broadening your mind it's turning you
into the kind of factionalist that the
founding fathers feared
so that's my most pessimistic take that
yes steve steve is right we had
incredible progress up until 2009 but in
the world after 2012 i think our
institutions uh that the institutions of
liberal democracy are in such danger
that it's quite possible that the future
will not be like the past i don't know
what's going to happen but i i now see
that as a possibility that i didn't see
five years ago and what do you see as
the danger at the moment
so the danger i think uh is that a
secular liberal democracy is a
miraculous thing but a fragile thing
and we briefly thought in the 1990s with
the fall of the berlin wall that this
was the end of history liberal democracy
had won
eventually north korea iran well
everybody's going to be a liberal
democracy once just once they get a
little richer they'll want that
but now it's clear that the founders
were right that a that a a that a
diverse democracy
a democracy
per se is very difficult very fragile
and as uh madison said as violent in
their deaths as they are short-lived in
their lives and so
the 20th century we had all kinds of
centripetal pressures including
especially world war ii uh binding us
together we had briefly a a
centripetal media system where we all
got the same news so there were we had
the high point of ju professional
journalism it wasn't that way before the
1920s and it isn't that way after 2012.
so there was this period where the
institutions that grounded us to truth
or rather gave us a process by which we
could make progress towards truth and
weed out terrible ideas
that it turns out was just a temporary
thing and i see it fading away
and this is uh so jonathan rauch has a
book coming out uh in a week or two
called the constitution of knowledge
steve is going to cover a lot of this in
in his book on rationality so let me
kick it over to steve steve you know
what do you see do you see that things
are changing the last 10 years or so in
ways that are a danger to a liberal
democracy such as ours
some of them are although in the last 10
years globally we've seen extreme
poverty continue to decline
we've seen uh war decline after the blip
from the syrian civil war which
temporarily reversed the trend we've
seen movements like the uh the
legalization of gay marriage in the
united states the uh restrictions and
the application of the death penalty so
there are a lot of these long-term
movements that are are continuing and
you also got to remember that in the 60s
and 70s
one thing domestically there were weekly
bombings and riots with police shooting
a dozen rioters a night
the the weathermen the black liberation
armies
liberation army i'm getting all of that
oh yeah things are things
materially things are continuing to get
better i give you all of that
uh and uh but but and and if you
listen back i mean i've been watching
the uh apple tv series 1971 year the
music changed everything oh cool highly
recommend it
it's a reminder of a lot of the
political inanity of our generation and
the our older brothers and sisters who
were uh maoists who were marxists who
were violent
insurrectionists and not just in
rhetoric but there really was a lot of
violence there were bombings there were
judges whose heads were blown off
it was a pretty uh ugly time and even in
terms of it's certainly true that there
is no um
overall progressive force toward liberal
democracy and there have there's
absolutely been a recession in the last
decade in countries like hungary and
turkey and the united states and
russia on the other hand if you look at
the graph of number of democracies
scaled by how democratic or how
autocratic they are we've backslid maybe
to 2010.
we have to remember that in the 1970s
there were only 33 democracies on earth
europe was behind the iron curtain spain
and portugal were literally fascist
dictatorships all of latin america you
know juntas banana republics military
governments taiwan was a military
dictatorship south korea was a military
dictatorship there has been some
backsliding but not back to the 1970s so
it's sort of premature to abandon
the liberal democratic uh ideal i agree
that has to be that there is some
it's not it's not so fragile that we
have gone all the way back to the the
1970s and there are some built-in
advantages like people want to live
there that's where people who vote with
their feet and up we know from i mean
john i know you you covered this in your
book on happiness but uh people in
liberal democracies are happier
and and together with
material affluence which of course
liberal democracies are very good at uh
delivering the second as i recall
a contributor to happiness is a sense of
freedom
so people there is at least pushing in
the direction of liberal democracy
against uh agreed the tribalists and
authoritarian and and backslid and um
magical thinking uh there is people's
desire for prosperity and freedom at
least for the for themselves
uh and
pushing back against the
kind of the the positive feedback loops
the vortexes of
misinformation and fake news and so on
there is the fact that you know reality
is that which doesn't go away when you
stop believing in it that and jonathan
roush is clear in his book which just
recently came out which i i admire as
much as you do that um that there are
some that because reality uh is still
there there's always a
a resource
to uh that the constitution of knowledge
what he called liberal science always
has behind it that in the end you can't
wish away reality for for long
see and i wonder i wonder if one of the
differences between now and the 1970s i
mean because i often think about now
compared to 1972 which was not exactly a
banner year that was the year of the oil
crisis
i mean it seems like
73 yeah 73.
it seems that there were
terrible things going on in the world at
that time that people were concerned
about
and they seemed equally concerned now
and equally divisive but the terrible
things aren't going on i mean
the vietnam war was raging the cold war
was raging we were concerned about
running out of oil and that seemed that
turned out to be you know another start
over population
yes i mean extinction yes yes so and a
lot of those things didn't manifest
themselves but certainly the cold war
was absolutely real and it and it was
raging away in in vietnam among other
places and so people were very uh bent
out of shape about that and rightly so
and now there seems to be an equal
amount of being bent out of shape but
the contributing factors seem even far
less obvious than they were in the 1970s
and so
that seems to be the mediating factor
between the position you staked out in
this discussion stephen and the one that
you're describing jonathan is that
you know it's not worse than it was in
the 70s except there's no reason for it
now
yeah
no no so i so i again i totally accept
steve's steve's points about progress
and about how there are many people
particularly as
he says progressives who don't want to
acknowledge that there's been progress i
don't deny any of that um i'm i just i
feel like
we're just in the first stages of this
new way of living in which we won't be
able to find
truth the processes that let us find
truth have decayed in ways that might
make the future different from the past
and so if you look at
uh what is happening in journalism and
many people now you know
not just people on the right but
centrists and others are saying the new
york times is just not as reliable as it
used to be since it's committed itself
um i heard a discussion but i think
andrew sullivan said something like
there was a you know a memo went around
that we're going we need to make race
part of every story
um so if uh you know if the new york
times has this this dual telos you know
this you know you know all the all the
truth that's fit to print
or is it all the truth that fits our
narrative we print i mean those are not
the same you know that's incoherence and
that's basically what's happened in some
of the social sciences as well uh and so
you have to either have the whole
institution committed to this really
really difficult thing which is
advancing towards truth
disposing of falsehoods using only
imperfect flawed
motivated
individuals as the units
and creating a process that nonetheless
gets you closer to truth and we've done
it
in universities we've done it in juries
in the court system the legal system and
we've done it in high quality journalism
and uh and now the truth we need that
truth and but we also need the truth
that unites us right i mean no
what's the truth that unites us well i
i'm trying to
to to make sense of of all the arguments
that you're putting forward i mean one
of the things that's happening
you pointed out is that we we're
factionalizing
and each faction has its own
representation of reality right and back
in the heyday of journalism and it
wasn't just journalism because there was
all sorts of central institutions that
people trusted fundamentally right and
so
those institutions were oriented towards
the truth in principle but they also
united people
and so now you could say that one of the
consequences of this
remarkable technology that's put us all
online is that
and this is part of what's undermining
journalism and that is everything has
fragmented into a thousand narratives or
ten thousand narratives and they all
find their own community and so
it it seems that the problem of truth
has two elements then what's the truth
and how is it that we share that across
ourselves so that we can be united as a
country or a state or whatever level of
community you choose okay i would just
be wary of saying the truth that unites
us as if we all need to believe one
truth i would rather say
if there is a possibility of finding
truth then at least we can have our
disagreements within some realm of
sanity where we might actually resolve
problems or fix problems or make these
massive advances on social problems
once the ability to find any kind of
truth goes away
then it's not that we
you know we can't unite around something
so you know if you think about when 9 11
happened
within a week you know we pretty much
there was a common agreement about what
had happened uh planes were sent by al
qaeda whenever we figured that out and
there were conspiracy theories that it
was in his inside job by israelis but
those were fringe freak theories nobody
really believed them um and you know we
came in america came together and
supported a response now of course we
you know george w bush abused that and
took us into a rock on false premises we
came apart but if 9 11 were to happen
tomorrow do you think that we would we
would
have a shared understanding of what
happened i don't and in fact it kind of
did you know we had the pandemic a year
and a half ago and it could have been a
way to bring us together to solve this
massive problem that we all faced um but
we quit in america at least we quickly
split into crazy factions yeah well i
should say i mean
you know crazy conspiracies theories on
the right the left wasn't conspiracy
theories but the left was the woke
problem where certain things you know um
certain things couldn't be said and uh
you know and especially the the you know
one of the worst things that the that
the institutions of that are
tasked with creating knowledge
one of the worst things they did was
they said no no no you can't get
together at church no no no you can't
get together at a trump rally oh but
black lives matter protests yes go ahead
and so that you know so the right was
already so skeptical and once the
epidemiological community did that as a
community they put out a statement boom
no more trust in the establishment and
that has killed a lot of people because
if not for that there would be a lot
less skepticism about vaccines
i i completely agree with john and
that's one of my favorite examples the
other one of course being that the uh
that if you discuss the possibility that
sars co2 originated from a lab leak in
wuhan that shows that you're a racist
you're a racist right
and so that was uh that that was uh
censored and inhibited until it just
burst for first out about a month ago
but while completely agreeing with with
john that that the our institutions for
finding the truth are constantly need
defense they go against a lot of
features of human nature
and then i just want to caution against
um
i think that it was that much better in
the past i mean one of my favorite
quotes is that uh the the best
explanation for the good old days is a
bad memory and this includes by the way
the new york times and there is a sort
of subversive book by ashley rinsberg
came out a couple of weeks ago called
the gray lady linked going over the
history of the new york times coverage
of world events which uh forget all the
news that's fit to print they downplayed
the holodomar the terror famine in
ukraine under stalin their berlin uh
chief during the 1930s was a nazi who
constantly apologized for the nazi
regime
the coverage of fidel castro in the 50s
amplified the strength of the guerrilla
movement the weakness of the loaded dm
regime in south vietnam leading to the
cia inspired coup may have been inflated
by new york times coverage there's
actually a history of activism
and
thank you for that i didn't know that
and here's another way of looking at it
again i don't want to be uh to
take on the optimist role
too thoroughly because i agree with john
a lot has gone wrong in the last uh uh a
few years
uh again the
constant vulnerability of the
institutions of liberal democracy and uh
truth-seeking
um
but um
where was i going with this
the um the best explanation is a bad
memory
yes right um
and the problem with an aphorism is that
it makes you forget what the original
point was
but that was a good approach but it's a
good aphorism
well we were talking about the new york
times and about the fact that it you
know it's never been what it was
and you you walked through that and and
the first one okay now here okay and one
i don't want to say it's a note of hope
that is that it will inevitably get
better but rather it's pointing a way to
what we ought to do if we want it to be
to get better which we we may or may not
succeed at
every new medium
opens up a kind of a wild west of
apocrypha of a carnival of nonsense this
happened with
the
the printing press the printing press
and with the
mass production of newspapers and
pamphlets and radio there was massive
plagiarism newspapers in the 19th
century reported the discoveries of sea
monsters and
miracles and revivals of the dead and
all kinds of
nonsense and it took a while for it to
settle into
norms that would allow people
got fed up with the nonsense
they did gravitate to the more reliable
sources but it took a while for those
norms and
fact checking mechanisms to be
implemented and online uh we have seen
the social media companies belatedly try
to keep people out of those
positive feedback loops those those
rabbit holes and we've seen and this is
a point that
jonathan roush and i independently made
in our books that online
media can actually implement a a regime
of uh fact checking and truth seeking we
see it in the contrast between the
social media like twitter and facebook
without the likes and the retweets which
seem to bring out the worst and
something like wikipedia which despite
its early rough years
you know we all have to concede this is
really really good
better than the alternatives they do it
because their rules of engagement were
different in a way that
since it's an unconfounded it's a
confounded experiment we don't know what
was the secret sauce but some of them
were the principles of commitment to
objectivity viewpoint neutrality
the mechanisms of uh pure correction
under the
um but not devolving into flame wars
although it does happen in the wikipedia
top pages but somehow they have they
managed to land on a set of rules that
that brought out a more rational side of
us and the
question is how do we
isolate what they did right and apply it
elsewhere right well it's it's
non-profit uh and it actually brings
people together for different viewpoints
there's an article that came out two or
three years ago showing that articles
about politics and social science that
had
uh political diversity in the authors
were rated as higher quality than those
that had less
so viewpoint diversity um is rewarded is
that's right it's it's one of the
essential features for a species that is
so committed to confirmation bias into
finding whatever supports my side or
what i've said publicly um so yes
wikipedia hit on uh it it used uh it
found a way to uh harness viewpoint
diversity to create a better product and
so yes i think we should put jon stewart
mill up on a pedestal and we should bow
down to him and we should have a new
religion we'll call it millionism or
millenarianism or no i don't know what
but something
so i guess i wonder if those
modifying
technologies
will be able to emerge in
in the new environment because things
change so fast
you know i don't know if we can evolve
corrective mechanisms faster than we
evolve new disruptive mechanisms
yeah so so we don't we have no idea what
to do with twitter for example and and
and no idea what effect it has we don't
have any idea i don't think what it does
to people's communication when you
truncate it to 280 characters like does
that increase the probability of
manifesting anger for example does it
and does anybody study that oh yes
there's a lot of research
bad is stronger than good as a general
principle there's a wonderful book by
roy baumeister and john tierney and so
bad spreads more than good um and
especially if if you strip away context
and intent and everything else you're
just asking for trouble
and so twitter is probably the worst
form of communication ever devised if
the goal is to actually have
conversations now it's great for certain
things it's great for finding things to
read
but to call twitter a communication
platform or a public square anything
like that
while it serves that function it serves
it about as badly as could be
so
um so i'm sure
what i sometimes say when i'm asked
about the future here is i say i believe
steve pinker is right that in 50 or 100
years things will be better
5 or 10 probably worse or at least may
well be worse but yeah in the long run
we're likely to figure this out
okay so we're going to say goodbye to dr
pinker at the moment thank you very much
for agreeing to talk with us today i
appreciate that and uh best of luck with
your new book hopefully we'll talk to
you again in the fall when it comes out
very good to see you nice to see you to
see you guys too bye
so let let's start by talking a little
bit about more about the righteous mind
okay and i'd like to know more about
your conceptualization
of
well conceptualization of religious
instinct religious impulse something
like that it's like how do you how do
you view that and why is it that you've
been asked to talk to uh gatherings of
religious people for example
yeah
so uh so the story that i tell in the
righteous mind
um
is that we
is that humans are products of
multi-level selection which means that
for the most part if you know if you
read richard dawkins for the most part
it's selfish genes create
create their survival machines animals
or plants and those survival machines
compete with other survival machines and
that's what we all know sort of textbook
darwinian evolution
but
while i love dawkins writing i love the
selfish gene
he for some reason says that
plants and animals are the vehicles that
the selfish genes travel on but groups
are not he just says groups can't be he
just rules that out if i remember
correctly
and uh for most species that works great
but for bees for example it obviously
doesn't work for bees it's obvious that
the unit isn't the individual bee it's
the hive where the the queen is the
ovary
and the argument that i make in the
righteous mind is that
humans show
signs of some group level selection that
is we are mostly we're primates we're
like chimpanzees and bonobos in a lot of
ways but we have this ability to lose
ourselves in something larger to become
completely unselfish to sacrifice for
the group that is unlike any other
animal that is not genetically 50 or
more
shared genes with all the other animals
in its group and
so uh drawing on on research on uh you
know early human origins and
especially the period around you know
from like a million years ago to to 200
000 years ago
it appears that we did live in groups
that competed with other groups um for
territory uh um over all sorts of things
and that often wiped out or killed other
groups
and so i think there was some degree of
of group level selection we are we are
everyone here on earth now is our genes
are not a cross-section of the genes
that were
on this earth 100 000 or 200 thousand
years ago
most groups left no trace and other
groups went on to spectacular success so
the way you see this is not by having an
argument about altruism which is where
the argument is usually done
steve pinker and i actually steve
disagrees with me on this steve uh
doesn't think that group selection
played any role but i think if you look
at groupishness or tribalism
why are we so tribal why do we love to
paint our faces and band together and
drink together and do all this stuff for
sports
why do we have these tribal responses
and i talk about my response on on 9 11
on september 11th i had this deep urge
to display an american flag like where
did that come from it was almost like a
jungian sort of like thing welling up
from my collective unconscious it was
weird but i had a real urge to display
an american flag but as a professor i
couldn't really do that because people
would think i was a republican so i
you know it's the solution i came up
with one way of marking yourself as not
a terrorist
is not a terrorist is to what
fly a flag i mean if you imagine that
your group is attacked
the first thing that's relevant is who's
with you and who isn't and i mean that
was made public politically by bush
right if you're not with us you're
against us and okay so that might be
part of a nativistic attempt to say look
guys i'm definitely on your side
i'm not trying to put it down yeah well
okay but uh yeah but you're suggesting
an individually adaptive reason for
flying a flag but you wouldn't need that
if we didn't have the groupish tribal
thing of let's kill people who aren't
going along with us so anyway to bring
this back to religion
my point is that we evolved in this this
dynamics of group versus group uh and so
uh and here i follow davidson wilson uh
you know in saying um you know conflict
within a you know conflict at any level
um brings about cooperation at the next
level down and so we come together to
compete to we cooperate intensely in
order to compete with other groups that
would be a hallmark of a long period of
intergroup competition which shaped
which genes
have come down to us today so anyway we
didn't evolve for big gods we didn't
evolve for you know for you know yahweh
and and um
and allah
um we evolved for
you know little gods and sprites and and
the the the god of this river and this
tree
uh and
and we evolved to worship our ancestors
and we evolved just this really intense
spirituality uh that manifests in a
magical world we have all of these
beliefs that don't track reality but
they do serve a durkheimian function
that is they do serve i believe not to
help us understand the world
but to bond together with others so that
we can survive in this world and
conflict and competition with other
groups
that's the durkheimian story and in the
righteous mind i i i was so pleased that
i could integrate two of my
my my heroes in the social sciences
which are durkheim and darwin they
actually fit together perfectly on the
subject of multi-level selection and
even on ideas of sacredness and and
groups coming together
so
that's my that's the approach i
developed to religion the righteous mind
i originally thought i'd write about
politics but the subtitle is why good
people are divided by politics and
religion because they're largely the
same thing psychologically
so that idea of the sacred so
i mean in order to
we might ask what are the preconditions
for being able to live peacefully with
other people
and it seems to me that
well you if we're all law abiding
for example
then we all embody the body of the law
and so what that means is that we're
imitating something
we're all imitating the same thing
and that's what makes us the same that's
why i
commented earlier in our conversation
that maybe what unites people isn't so
much belief as the pursuit of something
like a shared ideal
yeah
yeah well okay well let me just develop
that a little bit because you talked
about what was sacred
and
it it seems to me that there's an
association between what's sacred and
what inspires awe does that seem
reasonable yes absolutely yes okay do
you think it's reasonable to presume
that the instinct for awe
is the same as the instinct for
imitation for mimicry
i don't think they're the same no i
don't think the same at all okay let's
go into that a little bit so so i'll
tell you why i think they're the same
and you tell me why you think they're
not if that's okay well please when
people
well
let me give you an example people can be
possessed by a spirit at a football game
and
their
teams are cooperating and competing in
the way that you described so there's a
tribal element but overall they're
immersed in cooperation because they're
all playing soccer
and then they're competing to put a
to hit a target fundamentally which is
the goal of most sports events is to hit
a target
okay so
the teams organize themselves into
hierarchies of talent etc essentially
there's a star perhaps the star makes a
phenomenal
athletic gesture and hits the target
and the entire stadium stands up and
spontaneously right
and because they're observing something
that inspires awe
and that aw inspiring act is to hit the
target
and they're all in that stadium
celebrating the act of hitting the
target i started to figure this out when
i looked into the
root of the word sin
because it's hamartia it means to miss
the target oh wow yes yeah wow is right
wow is right and so the opposite of that
is to hit the target okay
okay so
you see in a stadium with that
spontaneous manifestation of awe
the possession of the entire stadium
often and it's almost entirely
unconscious because they get up on their
feet before they think
and it's an act of worship essentially
for that
prowess shown for that demonstration of
how to hit the mark
and that's part of the imitative spirit
i think it's part of imitating
what's competent and heroic
okay so i disagree with that analysis
because i'm i'm a dirk heimian i i just
what would emil durkheim say about that
is it that people are so amazed at the
skill with which that guy kicked a ball
into a net i don't think so
um
sports events of the kind you describe
you know that never happens with soccer
in the united states for us it's more
football and sometimes basketball
but of the kind you described it's um
the pleasure
anybody listening to this can probably
think of times when they either sung in
a choir or played in a band or played on
a sports team and you have that feeling
of really becoming one
that is that is a i would say a
quasi-mystical or mystical experience
it's a sort of a loss of self-emerging
into something larger yes that's my
argument about this higher and lower
level the level of the sacred level of
the profane
and durkheim describes those those are
crimean terms he uses those terms we can
briefly enter the realm of the sacred
and if you're going to go see a football
game would you rather have an excellent
view of the game alone in a room with an
excellent screen or maybe even just an
excellent window
would you rather be part of the whole
crowd that does the wave i mean think
about the wave no i agree with you
spontaneously figured out how they could
become a super organism
no no i'm not disagreeing at all and i i
do think it's look there's a collective
element of that worship that's exactly
in keeping with what you're describing
and it does unite people
in the imitation of a spirit in exactly
the same way that they're united in a
concert
or when they're playing in a band i
think those are all manifestations of
the same thing and so i'm not saying
that it's only individual by any stretch
of the imagination because there'd be
nothing that would unite see in the
stadium they're united around that right
okay so let's focus on imitation here i
guess the reason i disagreed with you is
that imitation is such an important
human ability for learning the fact that
we you know and here i draw from joe
henrik and others uh their approach to
cultural evolution joe's book uh you
know why humans cooperate and the
weirdest people in the world and um so
uh
hume for humans the nature of the game
is not who has the biggest strongest or
the biggest teeth it's who learns the
most who learns the best and we have all
this optimization for learning fast
and imitation is a big part of that so
we do imitation but we do selective
imitation and we figure who should i
imitate so
so that would be a sort of a very sort
of a lower level ubiquitous crucial
human ability that we have has nothing
to do with religion nothing to do with
awe but then i think we can bring our
accounts together by saying now then we
also have this
thing about we're able to come together
in larger groups to pursue common
interests especially in competition and
as we do that we use our imitation
abilities we draw on our imitation
abilities and so religious worship you
know and well yeah it actually it's
always puzzling in judaism you know you
dove and you you bow but it's not in
sync so that one is i think a little
different but a lot but you know often
you sing you sway in harmony um you you
know you do what everyone else does and
so uh that's to a tone
oh oh
that one
at one month atonement
oh at one minute yes absolutely
yes so let's go back to imitation so
okay okay
so
look when children
when the sun acts out the a father when
he's playing house
he doesn't
imitate his father
by which i mean you could observe the
father walking across the room and
making certain motions and the sun by no
means precisely duplicates those motions
what the sun does
is observe the father across a wide
variety of contexts extract out the gist
and imitate the gist yeah okay so you
made the claim that what we're imitating
is the capacity to learn
but i would modify that and say no we
we're imitating the capacity to explore
and there's a difference there while the
difference is that
learning is in some sense it has the
connotation of a kind of passivity
whereas did you ever see that medieval
drawing of the of the sky
uh all covered with stars and the man on
the edge of the earth with his head
poking through the firmament does that
bring a bell no an actual medieval
drawing or a modern part
no no it's a it's a medieval drawing it
doesn't matter but it's to boldly go
where no one has gone before you know in
the modern parlance while there's
there's a narrative that drives that and
that's the thing that's imitated and and
um
i think all of those collective
manifestations of immersement in the
sacred that you're describing
are opportunities for people to
collectively engage in
attention to and elevation of
something like that
wait uh so we certainly are an
exploratory species and just as you know
when i was a kid you know you you put a
you get a mouse or a gerbil as a pet you
put it into cage it's going to explore
so you know mammals are very exploit
many of them are very explorative human
children are too
is that what you i'm sorry you're saying
this is what religion is somewhat
related to our exploratory instincts
what do you mean yes that it's that it's
a manifestation of our attempt to
abstract out what the essential element
of that is so for example in
christianity i think the the
faculty that's elevated to the highest
degree is logos
and of course that's translated into
logic by the greeks but that that isn't
exactly all it means it means more like
exploratory communicative
endeavor but also with a tremendous
emphasis on the truth and i traced that
development back for example into egypt
and into mesopotamia the egyptians
worshipped the eye
horus's eye
and that's the attentive i it's not
rationality precisely it's the ability
to see what's in front of you it's the
opposite of willful blindness and the
the egyptians characterized it as such
because the god of egyptian attention
horus was the antidote to osiris and
osiris was the blindness of the state he
was the state and the blindness of the
state the egyptians had that all figured
out and in mesopotamia the highest god
marduk he had eyes all the way around
his head and he spoke magic words and he
was the victor
of a battle between the whole sequence
of gods competition between gods that
was likely
the abstracted result of competition
between tribes and their own you know
local religions
because monotheism seem to emerge like
that imagine all these tribes with their
local gods
they come together
when they come together the gods fight
so to speak and then over some immense
period of time they arranged themselves
into something approximating a hierarchy
and whatever is the ultimate principle
that the cultures
assuming they didn't destroy each other
derived
starts to take place so you see each of
these local gods is an element of an
ideal
and as they struggle across time the
ideals arrange themselves according to
whatever principle generates ideals and
something that something emerges at the
top
the question is what is it that always
emerges at the top
there's a pattern and it's the thing
that we imitate
that's the crucial thing wait i'm sorry
what emerges out of the top give me an
example
well like okay i can give you an idea
i'll give you an example okay you tell
me what you think about this because
it's expressed in all sorts of ways
because it can't be articulated not
fully okay so
you see byzantine cathedrals
the the dome is the sky
okay
the cathedral's across right
the center of the cross is the central
point of being okay
you look up at the sky and there's a
picture of christ as pantocrator as
creator of the world okay what's the
idea and he's in gold
there's a halo the halo is like the sun
and gold is is a noble metal right it's
pure and incorruptible so that ties into
that disgust issue that you've made so
much of
the logos idea is the idea that truthful
speech brings
about the best kind of reality it's
something like that
and so that's elevated so you think well
look
you know we imitate
you know we imitate the gist
well what is the gist extracted out over
thousands of years
see when i look at religion from a
purely psychological perspective let's
say
and think about
our continued discussion about what
constitutes the human ideal something
personified it has to be because we
can't imitate it otherwise that's the
problem with
abstract ideals as
as uh motivating
they're not personified you know even
when stephen talked about
the civil rights movement he had to
mention john f k and and martin luther
king right he had to bring the
personality into it yeah yeah so you
think as we've organized our religions
across time as we've aggregated into
groups and attempted to construct a
monotheism
we're trying to figure out what
principle should be elevated to the
highest state
yeah okay so so okay i think we we we
take we're taking a very different
approach to religion uh i
am a social functionalist
i i
i start by saying what's the social
function of this i don't think humans
are very motivated to find the truth now
this is not this is my particular view
um there's a saying attributed to robert
zions a great social psychologist that
um cognitive psychology is social
psychology with all the interesting
variables set to zero so a lot of people
try to use psychology to explain you
know how people trying to optimize their
information processing you know sure we
do that if we're trying to bet on the
stock market or if we're trying to get
from here to there
but even then we we do all sorts of
irrational things once you bring in the
social factors those tend in my mind to
overwhelm
any sort of truth seeking and once you
bring in religious uh thinking
where so much is done that is so
evidently counter to truth and many
people point out well the point of
believing something hard to believe is a
demonstration of of your commitment yeah
i've heard that i don't buy that
argument i don't think it's weak yeah i
don't know what to think about that
particular argument well here okay let
me let me ask you this
so if i said i believed in you
what would that mean
well pragmatically it means you support
me you're there for me you think i'm on
the right track
i have faith in you
yeah
right so what that would mean i think
and it would mean that i
uh
of your own accord i would expect you to
do the right thing
and i would rely on that and defend you
and so
the reason i'm bringing this up is
because
that's one of the ways that people use
the idea of belief
right it isn't we have this idea that to
express a religious belief is to express
accordance with a set of facts
like scientific facts but that is how it
see no
tis
you talked about ancestor worship
okay
we believe in something like the central
animating spirit of mankind
we that's the gist that we're all
imitating and that's what unites us
we're united around that ideal and you
see that expressed in places that you
described already
when you're playing with a band that's a
remark i'd love to be able to do that i
can't do that but i see people doing it
you can get a sense of that in the
audience
yeah you're united around something
transcendent
it seems and you're all imitating right
because you're all you've all got the
beat
you're all imitating the music
well and you're all right i would just
say you're insane it's not that you're
imitating per se
it's that you're moving as one
music though as well as moving at one
your image well you are from a piagetian
perspective because you're matching your
body to the rhythms right so you're
you're so the mimicry is embodied
and that's what unites you so you could
say you're knighted by the spirit of
music that's fine but i think it does
tap into that imitative capacity because
everyone does move as one yeah i would
agree whether you know i don't know
enough about mirror neurons to say
whether those i don't know what the
current state of research is on mirror
neurons but we certainly have this
ability to match to match each other's
movements uh and that is part of
imitation and that does get us in sync
uh and you know some people say this is
why you should go for a walk if you're
working out a conflict or a problem or
you're negotiating because physically
moving in sync with the person
tends to promote more agreement you know
i'd like to see that
validate i'm not very positive that's a
finding that holds up but but that makes
a lot of sense to me
so uh i think we're both focusing on
different aspects of
of the religious experience and i'm
coming in as a social psychologist
looking at social effects and you're
coming up as a clinical psychologist but
you're also not writing it off as like a
superstitious equivalent to rationality
like you're trying to tie it to
something that's oh we evolved to be oh
we evolved to be religious okay so that
part of our nature okay so that's the
first issue is okay so you think that's
a reasonable proposition
all right so then the question is what
exactly does that signify so let me try
running something else by you okay
you're interested in
processes of natural selection
now
so i made the proposition a little
earlier that
we are doing something like collective
imitation of the ancestral spirit that's
like that's what ancestor worship is it
unites a culture something like that you
reflect your father he reflected his
father etc all the way back
and so and the only way that we can be
in agreement about something is if we
share a lot of our presuppositions i
mean we can differ to some degree but we
have to have
i we have to have a shared personality
to comprehend one another
e.o wilson said you know if we could
talk to ants we wouldn't have anything
interesting to say to them yeah that's
right right right so you know our
similarities and our differences make
communication possible but the
similarity is something like
well it's our participation in our
shared culture even our shared language
yeah i don't know i think if if you if
you are on a team with someone if you're
on a boat that almost capsizes and you
and seven other passengers you don't
speak any languages in common but yet
you struggle together
um
you know you'll be friendly forever
especially if you do sort of speak each
other's language you can communicate a
little
so again that's okay i'm not i'm not
trying to localize it to a specific
subculture okay wow
okay well i just met that i just i'm not
sure we need common beliefs in order to
feel that we're part of one i think we
need to move together face a common
enemy together
i just don't put as much stock in
what do you think unites us if we face a
common enemy together
i think we evolved to have the ability
to go into team mode very quickly
and this is why um
teams and the army and other places
can do a really good job of suppressing
racial animus because
race doesn't matter when you're on a
team
right okay so that's fine that's fine so
let's take the example of a team that's
that's perfectly acceptable to me
because teams can be of any size
essentially yeah
i would say that there's a
central
what would i say the team has a
personality
in a sense
that's fragmented and represented by
each of the
players on the team so there's a unity
that the team consists of
that's represented in each of the
players
and that's what constitutes the the team
element of it
okay so so when we talk about
personality it's hard to say exactly
what we mean we mean something like an
animating spirit a pattern of action a
pattern of perception something like
that there's no reason to assume that
can't be shared between people
and i think that's the kind of seizure
that you're talking about when you see
people collectively participate in
something they regard as sacred
there all could be
okay that seem that seems reasonable
the question would be then what what's
the gist of that central uniting
principle the reason i'm asking this in
part you'll you'll appreciate this i
think
there's a claim
quite common at the moment that the
central animating principle of western
culture is power
oh yeah yeah
okay it's a it's a popular claim
yep okay
right what's the appropriate counter
claim that there is no central animating
spirit or that that's not it
that i faced this a lot and um
i think the response is to say
sometimes power matters and there are
those who believe that everything is
sexuality and sometimes sexuality
matters and there are those who believe
that everything is money and sometimes
money matters and sometimes self-esteem
people sometimes pain sometimes joy and
like sometimes jealousy right exactly
okay so that's that's people's first
response to everything is power
structures power structures power
structures you know you kind of know
what they think because it's uh yeah you
might know how they act too
yeah yeah so um
you know if you if you if you think that
anything whether it be the western
tradition or
or college is all about power
um i mean that's just sad well it's also
completely
i i've thought this through and then i
thought about all the people that i've
admired in my life who were successful
and so those would be people that i'd
like to imitate or at least i respect
and that seems to be a reflection of
something like you know a low level of
awe
they weren't admiration they were
driven by power
that's right they were driven by
competence and generosity
that's right and there you go and so
this is actually one of the hallmarks of
a religion
is um
people are committed to something that's
obviously not true on its face
and the people are really committed to
this religion that everything is power
this sort of michel foucault religion
they even interpret family life as being
about power you know that my
relationships with my kids is primarily
about my power i mean that's just
bizarre marriage
yeah that's right because i'm a man and
my wife's a woman therefore i must be
motivated to have power over my wife and
i must feel something in common with
other men because we're all men we're
all trying to maintain the power
structure i mean this is far wackier
than saying there was this guy and he
was killed and he came back to life
three days later i mean
you know it's this is just a matter of
faith and so the fact that it is
intruded so deeply into the academy now
again not in most departments but in you
know some of the departments that you
and i both know this is the religion
everything's about power yeah well we
don't seem to have been able to put
forward a very good counter claim
but i think it's as we're talking about
with steve the good counter claim
is something which you have to sort of
reason through and it's about process
more than any particular person and we
need equal treatment by the in front of
the law and you know we did all these
things uh and it's not as inspiring yeah
but there's another problem with it too
it's not like i don't have sympathy for
that viewpoint and there's nothing wrong
with a reasoned argument
but
look
whatever's at the bottom of the woke
movement is critical of the processes of
reason themselves
right
because everything is white supremacy
well
everything is up for grabs at least
right so it's a radical critique of
enlightenment thinking it's also an
attempt to identify enlightenment
thinking specifically with western
european thinking which i think is a
great mistake but it doesn't matter i
don't think that those
it isn't obvious to me that those merely
rational responses are going to do the
trick
now in general not but
something that i've begun to think a lot
about is the importance of
specifying the institution or the domain
before you say anything
else and so we can talk about will a
rational argument persuade people and if
we're talking about like
on planet earth you know or just you
know out on the public square not your
odds are not very good
and so the trick to having a good
society is one in which
there are domains within which people
have a set of
be it professional norms or norms about
how we do things and so the norms in a
college seminar class should be very
different and much more generous and
much more about building on each other's
arguments and and can critiques um
than it is on twitter and part of what's
changed part of why i keep saying the
world is so different after 2012 than it
was before 2009
is that
social media knocked down all the walls
between different domains
and now the norms of the norm
the norms in with the norms within which
a reason discussion among people who
have basic respect for each other and
are tied together at least as fellow
students or fellow jury members or
whatever
when that goes away and everything is
just the public square well then yeah
we're not really able to have
recent conversations anymore
so what do you think
so you attribute what's happened since
2012 fundamentally to to technological
transformation is that is that the case
yes there were a variety of trends that
were building already but those included
technological changes like the emergence
of cable tv in the 1980s
but between 2009-2012 that was when we
passed a kind of a tipping point or a
phase change i would say
in which everything got weird right
after 2012.
do you think it has anything to do with
lack of a shared vision for the future
well it you know a liberal democracy
doesn't need a shared vision and we
never really had a shared v well i
shouldn't say that there was an idea of
what it was to be an american there was
it wasn't held by everybody uh and
obviously for a long time it excluded
african americans and and and um yeah
and a fair bit of that was materialist
progress right the instantiation of the
yeah exactly what right that's right
once you once you don't need somebody
doing full-time laundry and and carrying
water
whatever you yeah material progress
allows people to live as individuals
um but um
let's see yes i i think the the phase
change was
um when we we're connected to each other
in ways
that bring out that that play on
aspects of our psychology that are
generally antisocial
and that
inhibited both our ability to connect to
people authentically and our ability to
find truth collectively i think we're
worse at both of those and that helps
explain why the more connected a
generation is the more depressed it is
gen z is the most connected generation
the most depressed generation they're
also the most lonely the more connected
you are the lonelier you are
because it's not real connection
is it also idiosyncratic
in what way
my connection network and yours aren't
the same
and my connection network and no one
else's are the same
that yes you know what i mean
yeah yeah so i think so so i believe
that we are ultra-social creatures we
evolved in groups in a sense we broke
out of the hive
in the you know 19th century 20th
century with prosperity we could live
alone we have individualism and so while
that's very good for certain things and
it certainly brings it makes it easier
to give everybody rights
but
many of us yearn for
groups we we are we i think we are at
our best we are at our happiest and we
have well-constituted groups and if you
think about the times i ask my mba
students think about a time in your work
life that was just the best like what
was the best job the best time in your
world so that's kind of why i asked
about shared vision it's like
i guess one question is what is it that
unites a group
you know
what
you can unite with someone else around a
shared activity which is usually
directed to some sort of goal
right so so there's there's there's an
ideal there that that might be pulling
you on you certainly do that if you're
participating in the sports team or
something like that like
do do we unite around a purpose
rather than beliefs
so so here i draw on mike tomasello
who's just a brilliant psychologist who
studied child development and chimpanzee
and chimpanzee development
and
he
said he shows our the he the great human
innovation i cover this in chapter nine
of the righteous mind
is shared intentionality
so if you have two chimpanzees
and um
and there's like a log and they could
carry the log over to the wall and tilt
it and climb out
they're smart as individuals they could
do that but if it takes two to carry it
they will never ever in a million years
do it because they don't they don't have
the ability to say we are doing this
thing together right well like two or
three kids do that yeah we signal that
with our eyes exactly to a large degree
right and they're even evolved for that
you can we have very uh legible visible
whites so we can tell where people are
pointing their eyes exactly that's part
of that ability to inhabit the same
spirit simultaneously that enables the
kind of cooperation that you're
describing that's right that's right
yeah and thomas ella points that out
that chimpanzees you can't see where
they're looking because everything is
brown and so it's not why do we look at
other people's eyes it's why do we
broadcast why do we give away this
valuable information it's because it
makes us a better partner for
cooperation you know yes it enables
other people to see what we're up to too
that's right and we're useful to them
and they're useful to us um
so i think that oh and there's also this
thing from tubia and cosmetics about
i forget they had a catchy name for it
but it's it's like crises that you face
together you know if you're attacked by
a neighboring group or if you fend off a
you know a lion
that act of like your life is in danger
but you and three others did it together
you're now you're really bonded that's
how you get really close friendships
and that i think is part of the reason
why gen z is so lonely
the rest until the 1980s or 90s kids
went out unsupervised and we all got
into scrapes and my best friends we all
got you know a couple times we had to
run away from the police a couple times
we
you know somebody got hurt how are we
going to get them back to their mom
you have you go through scrapes together
that's what bonds you i don't think you
need a shared belief i don't think you
need a shared vision i think you need
shared activities where you are
interdependent you rely on each other
and that's why the army works so well at
least it didn't
through the vietnam war but they really
got serious about this about race issues
in the in the 80s i think it was at any
rate so i guess you and i just we
disagree i mean i'm sure you are
thinking of cases that i'm not thinking
of where it's the shared vision that
matters
but as a social psychologist
i think the shared vision is not
necessary it's really doing things
together yeah yeah well i i don't i it's
not like i disagree with the idea of the
necessity of doing things together
i'm always
fascinated by this idea of
gist because we're so good at
abstracting out the essence from things
you know and so
you you said for example that maybe you
catalyze a friendship in a crisis yes
and a crisis indicates what's important
when push comes to shove so to speak
that's right right and so then you
manifest
what you
self-sacrificing behavior in the face of
danger something like that
well i would say it's not what's
important who's important it shows you
who's important who's on your team right
but then who's important would be
willing to do that yeah they put
themselves at risk for you
yeah something like that so that's
self-sacrificing behavior
yeah
that's reasonable yeah it does it does
uh and you know even in an office you
know my kids love
the office and it's about the
dysfunctions of office life and i i did
work in office for two years in between
undergrad and grad school i was a
computer programmer for the government
uh and we had a really bad boss
and though you know and i'm still bonded
to my my co-workers we suffered together
we
you know intrigued and plotted together
you know we did things together and we
were very diverse ethnically and
somewhat politically but we all went
through this thing together and worked
together
so back to the righteous mind how did
your work on did your work on disgust
lead you in that direction
yes it did it was the breakthrough
because um when i was a first year grad
student beginning to study moral
psychology it was all about lawrence
kolberg and jean piaget and it was very
rational and was about how kids beliefs
about justice and fairness change as
they develop
and it was a little bit dry and dull and
it wasn't until i took a cultural
psychology class with alan fisk who's a
brilliant cultural anthropologist and
psychologist and he had us read
ethnographies you know full-length
treatments of cultures from around the
world
and
it was there that i saw these patterns
these repeated patterns around
menstruation food taboos um you know
orders or yeah that's right there are um
and so that's what really showed me this
as i said it's like a jungian view like
there's something in our minds that is
coming out all over the world you know
culture can't be just you know we're not
a blank slate i wish steve was still
here we're not blank slates cultures
can't just teach you you know from each
according to uh his ability to reach
according to like you can't teach that
to people that's the way we are in a
family but you can't make a whole
society believe that because there are
constraints and it was studying
uh disgust at purity pollution and then
discussed with paul rosen who happened
to be at the university of pennsylvania
where i was a graduate student it was
really studying disgust and sanctity and
purity and religious practice around
that you know why is the body so
important in religious practice except
in modern protestantism
and so that's what got me to be look at
this much more irrational stuff to think
about evolution in a certain way and
that led me to multi-level selection so
yeah if not for disgust i probably would
have just been somebody studying
relatively dry aspects of moral
psychology about reasoning and fairness
right that takes you down into the
emotional and the instinctual exactly
that's right that's right disgusting
yeah and there's a big debate in um
you know in moral psychology um there's
a very it's a very active exciting field
but there are people who say well no
it's all about harm everything's
ultimately about harm and everything
else is indirectly harm and there others
say no no it's all about fairness
everything is fairness uh and i am a an
anti-parsimonist that is
um i do not believe in the pursuit of
parsimony i believe well the problem is
is the terms that that everything gets
reduced to start to expand
what do you mean well if you say
everything is about harm then you have
to redefine harm so that it's right
exactly exactly exactly so it it does it
does seem to be a
a mug's game in some sense and it
enables you to have one answer for
everything which is really
helpful yeah so
um i was reading friends to wall
recently and he's
studied discussed quite i didn't realize
that disgust did manifest itself in
other animals so clearly it's
controversial there are there are some
hints of it in some primates that i've
heard of but it's
i don't think any other animal shows
contagion the way we do but give tell me
his if he has an example well he thinks
dogs show disgust to citrus fruits which
are poisonous
well they'll do it to the smell too yeah
but it's just his taste no this is so
paul one of the things i got from paul
rosin who's one of the world's experts
on food and eating the psychology of
food and eating is of course animals
evolved to seek out certain
sense you know sensory experiences that
guide them to their food so if you're a
koala bear if it smells like eucalyptus
you're done uh but if you're a dog
um you revolve to eat meat and and you
know when you're a kid like you think
well grapes are so delicious i love
grapes you know phyto why won't you why
don't you like this grape you won't eat
a grape
um and so that's just distaste and so
what rosin what i learned from working
with paul rosen is this taste is very
common you're reacting to the sensory
properties of the food so that's not so
interesting
what's interesting is that something
that elicits a negative reaction
touches something else
will you then avoid that something else
so he's tracked that in chimps
oh contagion tell me
well he tracked one chimp who found a
dead rat
and
used it to torture other chimps with
okay and so she would place the dead rat
which was in rough shape on another
chimp possibly sleeping the chimp would
wake up be horrified and then rush off
to clean
that's really funny wow practical joke
that is so funny because my my college
roommate and i did something kind of
like that in college he had a snake and
he had dead rats in the room to feed the
snake and we actually did something very
much like that this is a riot
now does that show contagion that they
needed to wash off
uh you know maybe yeah well he does he
has other uh other accounts
where is this last mama's last hug it's
called is that his is that a book of his
i don't know yes yes mama's last talk
it's a relatively recent one yeah yeah
well i was quite very influential in my
thinking yeah i loved to also yeah me
too well and and i'm so interested in
your work on disgust and so it was
interesting to me because i thought it
was a relatively human emotion but he
makes a pretty strong case that is more
but but as with so much about chimps you
can say do they have culture well you
know there's this behavior here that was
observed once or ten times you know that
what you're telling me now is the first
case i've ever heard that looks like
maybe it was so
with so much about chimps do they have
it well
almost a little bit and sometimes you
know so
you know there's not bright lines but
there are some sort of
somewhat right yeah well i guess with
disgust you'd think that it was
sufficiently
uh embodied visceral so that
it might have fairly pronounced
equivalence in
in
species that are closely related to us i
do wonder about its relationship with
conscientiousness
which seems to be important yeah or more
specifically human trait perhaps maybe
you see it in sled dogs i don't know
yeah no i do think uh so you know maybe
you can tell me about freud's anal triad
whether there's any truth to that but at
least if you if if you think that human
personalities like the master dimension
is sort of are you more set towards like
approach explore mode or are you more
set to finding threats and and defend
mode and that's a trait that varies
and people who are more set to defend
mode are going to be more anxious but
also more disgust sensitive uh there's
you know there's a small correlation
with politics they tend to be a little
more conservative um and conservatives
certainly are more conscientious um
especially orderly they're especially
more orderly and that seems to be more
tightly associated with disgust
sensitivity that's right
as opposed to say straight neuroticism
yeah
that's right what do you think of randy
thornhill's work on on on
uh parasite prevalence and conservatism
which seems yeah to be logically
associated at least to some degree with
your work on disgust
yeah it is i mean i know the the
hypothesis
i think it makes a lot of sense i i
don't i'm not
so cross not so basically the idea that
uh cultures that evolve with high
parasite loads
other people are much more dangerous
you're much more uh uh you know careful
about outsiders coming in they bring
disease and so conservatives tend to be
more
um you know actually a nice metaphor in
the brexit context are we drawbridge up
people or are we drawbridged down and
the brexiters were more drawbridged up
you know
here you know here's our our island and
the more universalist you know uh
remainers we're more garbage down and
over and over again you see
uh
the you know the progressive mindset is
much more john lennon imagine no borders
just everybody living in peace
uh and the conservatives
might be the fundamental political
difference i i thought this because you
know the two traits that predict
political beliefs seem to be openness
yeah predicting liberalism and the kind
of things that you're talking about yeah
and and orderliness
and so if you put you think why do those
co-vary to predict political belief and
it seems to me to be something very much
like what you just described with
relationship to borders is
are you on the side of free flow
because you see the advantages or are
you afraid of that because of perhaps
because of pathogen contagion
yeah that's right and so here's a very
useful word it
once you hear it it just explains it
really it improves things here
there's been a debate for a while about
whether conservatives are authoritarian
whether authoritarianism is exclusive
the promise of the right a long search
for left-wing authoritarianism i think
there is such a thing you you know you
think so too actually right you've
produced some research on that
but i i heard an interview with john
hibbing who's a political scientist
political scientist who's done a lot of
research on sort of the physiology or
brain basis or
uh you know uh
the psychology of politics
and he says the word we use shouldn't be
authoritarian it's not primarily
authoritarian it's primarily
securitarian
people who are really focused on
security
they want us to be safe they see threats
over the borders if that's if that's the
way your mind is more then you will end
up more attracted to parties right of
center whereas if you're less concerned
about security then you go more left of
center and boy is this playing out in
new york city right now because uh you
know we had a horrible crime wave that
went on for decades in this city it
ended in the 90s and it seems to be
picking back up as of two or three
months ago i mean it increased during
the pandemic but the last couple months
my neighborhood's gotten really much
more dangerous um uh you know more
crimes
new york was so good for so long yeah my
wife and kids could walk around it you
know at 11 o'clock at midnight they
could walk around you know
millennials were taking the subway out
to brooklyn at four in the morning uh
and you know i hope that'll come back
but in the last couple of months it
looks like it's back to the seventies
anyway the reason i bring it up is just
to say
that in we're having a mayor's uh a
mayoral election that the primary's
going on right now and election day is
tomorrow and back when it seemed like
everything was great we're gonna come
out of this you know one set of
candidates was was attractive uh but now
it's you know oh really you said defund
the police no way like no we need the
police we actually really really need
the police so there's you know as soon
as there's a real threat many people not
just conservatives many people suddenly
say wait a sec security is really
important
and do you think that that this is
particularly german question to you
we tried to look for heightened levels
of anxiety and conservatives in my lab
for a long time we never found them not
really right
but yeah but it's the disgust issue
that's so germane to me it's like
when you say security do you mean
control of what's contemptible and
disgusting or do you mean what's
threatening those are not the same thing
yeah i think following hitting i think
it's what's threatening now because
you're right the neuroticism if anything
is more common on the left
conservatives are happier by some
measures not by all
there are a variety of psychological
traits that do seem to indicate greater
psychological adjustment among
conservatives
and including happiness
and so
i would not be weird to say that
conservatives are more anxious but yet
they do seem to be more threat sensitive
would you agree with that i don't know
like i i wrote a whole book
sort of theorizing that the purpose of
belief was to
bring anxiety under control and
uncertainty and there's something to
that but
disgust has has
you know
occupied more and more in my imagination
with regards to political belief partly
because of your work
um
partly because of randy thornhill's
partly because there is an association
between orderliness and conservativism
and orderliness and disgust sensitivity
and that's it's not associated with
neuroticism which is so strange right
because the negative emotions clump
together
you're right so you'd expect that really
it's a killer piece of evidence if
conservatives are more threat sensitive
they should show higher levels of
neuroticism on some measures and they
just don't
and so you could you can see in lab
situations there are some stimuli they
seem to overreact to but
it isn't obvious that it's associated
with the canonical negative emotions but
disgust is i hold and yeah you know
after i
familiarized myself with your work
i read hitler's table talk
which is
what is that it's a collection of his
spontaneous utterances over dinner time
collected by his secretaries across
about four years oh fascinating yes it's
fascinating and what's really
fascinating is how much of it's about
disgust oh wow god it's just
unbelievable because his propaganda
process cockroaches rats
so much discussed you may know this and
you may not that zyklon was originally
used as an insecticide in factories they
cleaned up the factories the the nazis
cleaned up the factories first
then the mental hospitals
then they broadened out and it was
cyclone b i believe to begin with and
then cyclone a
and so there's a disgust story there
that's unbelievably strong and the thing
about things that are disgusting if
you're afraid of them you want to get
away from them yeah if they're
disgusting you want to destroy them
well you yeah you want to withdraw from
them yes yes you want to withdraw and
you want especially burning yeah yes
it's the most satisfying way to dispose
of things so that yeah it kills right so
it's not like the nazis weren't enamored
of the symbolism of fire burning that's
right that's right
yeah so i think maybe what we can say
here
is that let's bring in openness to
experience because if we say that
openness to experience is consistently
the largest trait associated with
politics as far as i know and so people
are high on openness to experience tend
to be
drawn to progressive or left-wing
politics and that has a very clear
negative relationship with disgust that
i think is the strongest relationship
we've ever paul rosen i ever found now
you would think that that would also
have some relation to anxiety because as
you said the negative emotions all clump
together but in this case they don't so
maybe maybe the neuroticism link is a
red herring maybe what we should be
focusing on is the openness to
experience so i'm assuming that hitler
was not very open to its new experience
that he did not seek out a great variety
of foods and curious about it it's very
complicated because he was
extraordinarily interested in aesthetic
issues he had the floor plans of most
major buildings memorized and he was
planning to transform the centers of
most of the cities that he conquered
into artistic citadels but but remember
that he divided that's right he divided
art into acceptable and and pathological
right so he was an artist with very
conservative tastes in what was
beautiful yeah so i think he was open
and hyper-orderly
hyper-orderly because he there's other
examples of his orderliness and disgust
sensitivity but are there other examples
four times a day wait a second
so you you've convinced me that he's
interested in aesthetics but do you
think he was open in a general way well
he wanted to go to art school he tried
to get in three times tried to make a
living as a watercolorist yeah yeah so
look i'm not trying to make a case that
hitler was an artistic genius not i'm
not saying that at all he was a very
complicated person but i think the real
tilt for him was
was maybe maybe even the contradiction
between openness and extreme orderliness
like he was also a
worshiper of willpower which is
associated with orderliness right so he
could stand like this would stand like
this for hours at a time and he prided
himself on that and he bathed four times
a day he's also concerned he's also very
much concerned with what he ate yeah you
know in an orderly sort of way that's
right it could take
contamination sensitivity exactly and
the way he saw jews in german society is
contaminating rats cockroaches yeah that
is very common in genocide that's the
same language in rwanda pure blood all
the time yeah yeah and so there's that
purity element that you've made so much
of as well that's just it's just a it's
an obsessive theme and if you if you
look at his table talk you can see that
because it's spontaneous utterances you
know and so i was looking for fear
words
anxiety words it's like they're rare
but disgust words fascinating that's
just it's just there all the time and
disgust it's you know you think about
our society we go out of our way to keep
fearful things at bay
but we really go out of our way to keep
disgusting things away yeah that's the
hallmark of civilization and the
civilizing process
right and when people travel in you know
what what used to be called third world
countries that was one of the striking
things is just the degree to which
dead bodies or death and excrement and
other things are visible parts of life
and boy have we done a good job hiding
them in uh yes that's that's just not
there at all at all so yeah right so we
don't even know how sensitive we are to
disgust anymore because almost all the
elicitors have been have been removed
that's right that's right
so okay well it's 5 30 over here i have
to head home for dinner uh but it's
always a pleasure to talk with you
jordan i uh i was going to say i never
know what we're going to talk about but
i always assume you'll have something
with politics psychology and disgust i i
appreciate the fact that you found my
disgust work and i uh useful and i found
your your writings about jung and
religion uh and certainly your
what you've written and said about the
current state of our universities uh to
be incredibly useful too so uh well
thanks very much for agreeing to talk to
me again and good luck with your
forthcoming book hopefully we'll get a
chance to talk again i'd like to talk to
you more about imitation and awe because
those are those are crucial okay
you know what so let's do this imitation
awe and psychedelics that's something
that we we talked about earlier uh so
some you know next time we get together
uh let's talk about uh imitation awe
psychedelic experiences and how they
change people
and how they
for for me at least opened me up to
unmoralizing things to to stepping
outside of moral matrices and
just trying to understand complex
systems yeah maybe it'd be a good idea
to pull in one of the psychedelic
researchers for that talk perfect yes
that would be much better than just you
and me talking about it yeah yeah yeah
yeah that would be good yeah all right
all right okay maybe next fall or next
winter yeah okay okay really good
talking to you and glad you're talking
about all that thank you you too bye bye
[Music]
you